[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce premier
numéro de la saison 7 8 2024 votre
émission sur l'actualité des jo de 2024
dans les yvelines sur tv 78 voici le
programme de ce 25 novembre 2021
l'institut de santé par à sport
connectés c'est le nom de ce site qui
doit voir le jour aux mureaux en 2024 à
l'occasion des jeux paralympiques le
projet se veut unique au monde pour
accompagner les personnes en situation
de handicap vers la pratique de ce sport
de tous niveaux le professeur françois
genest président de l'iace pc synergie
est notre invité est la discipline fait
son entrée au programme olympique le
break dance sera l'un des sports
additionnel de paris 2024 et les
épreuves se dérouleront place de la
concorde à paris fort de cet engouement
le troisième ultimate battle masters se
déroulait à poissy en octobre
l'événement a pour ambition de devenir
un tournoi préparatoire aux jo et puis
en septembre et en octobre les drapeaux
olympiques et paralympiques sont passés
par deux fois à saint quentin en
yvelines étape symbolique sur le
territoire qui accueille quatre sites de
paris 2024 et nous sommes désormais à
974 jours des jeux olympiques de paris
c'est parti pour ce 7,8 2024
[Musique]
un chiffre pour commencer 3,9 milliards
d'euros c'est le budget estimé de paris
2024 à 97% financée par des ressources
privées mais le soutien de l'état pour
ces jeux olympiques à la mi novembre a
été validée les députés ont voté en ce
sens l'article 39 du projet de loi
finances pour 2022 le texte actualise
l'engagement auprès du comité
international olympique et du comité
d'organisation des jeux et introduit
également une garantie générale de
l'état et ce dans le cas d'un déficit
jusqu'à présent la seule ville de paris
et est responsable pour combler une
éventuelle perte en tant que signataire
du contrat de ville hôte est à moins de
3 ans désormais de cjo quelques points
restent à éclaircir notamment le lieu de
la cérémonie d'ouverture le président de
la république emmanuel macron avait
annoncé un événement hors du stade or
d'un stade est directement sur la scène
et dans une interview au journal
l'équipe tony estanguet le président de
paris 2024 a rappelé la nécessité de
valider officiellement la faisabilité de
cette cérémonie sur la scène il a
indiqué s'être entretenu sur le sujet
avec le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin sur les questions de sécurité
est la volonté de l'ancien champion a
acté le projet de cette cérémonie le 13
décembre prochain et date du prochain
conseil d'administration de paris 2024
tant qu'on n'a pas le lieu on ne peut
pas commencer à recruter des gens qui
travaillent sur des concepts on ne peut
pas multiplier des frais pour rien fin
de citation à prévenu tony estanguet
[Musique]
26 pays réunis durant trois jours au
gymnase des pyramides à voisins le
bretonneux du 9 au 11 novembre dernier
le club skipping à organiser le ski par
att french open une compétition de
tennis de table handisport avec des
têtes d'affiché mondiale certains
athlètes étaient même aux derniers jeux
paralympiques de tokyo amical et demi
d'euros et bixente mais a senti steban
26 pays réunis pendant trois jours à
voisins le bretonneux le club skipping
organise au gymnase des pyramides le sky
par att french open et compétitions
handisport avec des têtes d'affiché
mondiale c'est une première on n'a pas
fait de tournée en france depuis 2014 où
ça s'était pas très bien passé et en
fait alors avec paris 2024 on devait
faire un tournoi en france et là c'est
si on va dire un des premiers tournois
sachant que je pense que si ça se passe
très bien les gens voudront venir et là
il ya des très très bon joueur la
compétition permet de proposer les onze
classes différentes présent dans le
tennis de table handisport en tennis de
table il ya onze classes différentes il
faut bien comprendre que selon que nous
sommes en fauteuil ou que nous avons un
déficit mental il se passe pas du tout
la même chose heures une table entre 11
classes différentes qui permettent de
répartir ses joueurs de façon à
équilibrer un petit peu les compétitions
en parallèle pendant ces trois jours de
tournoi le rendez-vous permet également
une vingtaine de classes de 50 ans livin
de découvrir le tennis de table
handisport
quand des jeunes viennent leur regard du
coût change sur le handicap et sur leur
capacité quand ils seront plus grands à
faire en sorte d'accueillir la diversité
donc pour eux on a imaginé un événement
et d un parcours qui leur permet de voir
les matches mais aussi deux semaines
après en situation la compétition se
poursuivra jusqu'à ce jeudi 11 novembre
si vous voulez assister à ce rendez vous
l'événement est ouvert gratuitement aux
spectateurs
elle vise une médaille aux jeux
paralympiques de paris 2024 la tennis
woman pauline déroulède se prépare en
vue de l'échéance est début octobre un
cours à son nom a été inauguré c'est au
domaine de la corniche harold boise un
lieu symbolique pour les sportifs qui
s'entraînent à feucherolles l'hôtel
restaurant est un lieu où elle a
l'habitude de venir en famille et c'est
l'un des premiers endroits qu'elle a
fréquenté après son accident en 2018 a
été fauché par un automobiliste et a
perdu sa jambe gauche on les écoute au
micro de mickaël landreau c'est la
preuve qu'on bâtisse d'un court de
tennis à mon nom c'est ça me fait très
plaisir ça me touche énormément parce
que voilà c'est pour la symbolique c
c'est plutôt sympa c'est une façon une
première façon de marquer le tennis
fauteuil le tennis mais mon sport depuis
toujours donc je suis honoré
handisport au coeur d'un dernier
symposium le dernier symposium sport
santé de l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines l édition 2021 se
dérouler le 24 septembre dernier à l'ufr
simone veil à montigny le bretonneux
l'occasion de présenter un projet
d'envergure l'institut de santé par à
sport connectés qui verra le jour aux
mureaux en 2024
c'est le projet phare de l'ue fr simone
veil santé de l'ue vs qu l'institut en
santé parra sport connectés qui sera lui
situé aux mureaux cet établissement
prévu pour 2024 sera dédiée au sport et
handicap
d'infrastructures spécialisées sur le
suivi médical la formation des
professionnels de santé et la recherche
et développement technologique
on est sur une dimension technologique
des exosquelettes de leur thèse de la
prothèse des fauteuils roulants et
également des aides techniques pour
pouvoir pratiquer du sport ainsi que lui
sera la structure opérationnelle le site
l'endroit le carrefour où physiquement
les gens se rencontreront à la fois les
chercheurs les enseignants les sportifs
et sportives tout venant et sportifs de
haut niveau et donc c'est cette vie en
commun cet échange permanent qui sera
source d'innovation des sportifs de haut
niveau des chercheurs des professionnels
de santé tous sont rassemblés pour le
3ème symposium sport santé de l'ufr
simone veil de l'ue vs qu l'occasion
chaque année d'échangés sur une
thématique cette année c'est le sport et
le handicap
du handicap est un thème prioritaire est
majeur de l'université et de l'ufr des
sciences de la santé
et donc c'est effectivement
un thème dans lequel nombreux projets
scientifiques sont développés en
particulier l'institut du sport
connectée du professeur françois jaunet
autres nouveautés présentées lors de ce
symposium la création du département
universitaire de médecine des activités
physiques et sportives
voilà pour ce sujet avec la voix de
michael et demi d'euros et qui a été
réalisé par patrick jacques de dixmude
et nicolas landry ont continué la
discussion sur cet institut de santé par
à sport connecter avec mon invité c'est
le professeur françois genest bonsoir
bonsoir et vous êtes le chef de service
médecine et réadaptation à l'hôpital
raymond-poincaré de garches professeur
des universités vous étiez également le
responsable de la délégation et médical
paralympique à tokyo 2020 et vous êtes
aussi et c'est pour ça qu'on vous invité
ce soir est le président de l'ihh spc
synergie c'est à l'association qui porte
ce projet à l'institut de santé par à
sport connectés je le rappelle son
ambition c'est d'associer la recherche
la formation et ce pour aider à la
pratique du sport pour les personnes en
situation d'handicap
l'ouverture est prévue en 2024 sur le
site de belleville aux mureaux comment
est née l'idée de ce projet m'a à l'idée
est venue quand on se rend compte
aujourd'hui dans notre discipline à
force de suivre des personnes en
situation de handicap que l'espérance de
vie ne fait qu'augmenter pour cette
population que la qualité de vie ne fait
qu'augmenter également et que cette
population ben finalement souffrent des
mêmes maux que la population générale à
savoir l'hypertension le diabète
l'obésité et qu'il fallait également
lutter contre ces fléaux la notion de
sport santé et on s'est rendu compte que
les personnes en situation de handicap
avait des difficultés pour se mettre au
sport et à l'activité physique et qu'il
fallait les aider et qu'il fallait que
la santé qui est souvent la porte
d'entrée à la pratique du sport par le
certificat d'aptitude la réserve de
pratique et bien s'emparent de ce sujet
et aide toute cette population a débuté
l'activité physique et le sport il ya
trop de francs aujourd'hui pour la
pratique du sport de ces personnes en
situation d'handicap pas forcément
forcément un petit peu on se retrouve
face à une somme de cas particulier
c'est pas une population homogène la
formation en santé n'est pas suffisante
pour que les médecins et les et
l'ensemble des professionnels
paramédicaux
soit suffisamment performant pour
pouvoir les accompagner il ya le
maillage territorial qui est parfois un
peu suffisant et puis il ya toutes ces
aides techniques comment les à voir
comment les construire et comment les
financer pourquoi la pratique du sport
aussi bien sur le plan sanitaire sociale
mental est elle bénéfique j'ai envie de
dire pour pour tout le monde pourquoi
c'est bénéfique la pratique du sport bah
on a remarqué que finalement dans notre
pays il appelait les stratégies de
prévention était un petit peu
déficitaire or en santé on est meilleur
quand on fait de la prévention que quand
on traite ça peut paraître paradoxal et
c'est vrai que l'activité physique et le
sport réduit tous les risques liés au
vieillissement liés à la sédentarité et
que c'est le premier traitement que
chaque français devrait infliger pour
pouvoir rester autonome est en pleine
forme alors le projet de 7 i/s pc si on
tente de le vulgariser on peut dire que
c'est un à nice 1-1 celle du handisport
l'institut national du sport de
l'expertisé et de la performance ou
plutôt même un i7 pour tous parce que sa
vocation c'est de sa drisse est pour
tous les sportifs de tous niveaux c'est
pas que le sport de haut niveau c'est
aussi pour la pratique loisir je
remercie c'est exactement ça notre
projet initial à l'origine c'est
vraiment accompagner toutes les
personnes en situation de handicap à la
pratique du sport bien évidemment on va
jusqu aux athlètes de traits de très
haut niveau et on se rend compte à
chaque fois qu'on a des des
représentants fort de champion dans des
disciplines par ruissellement et bien ça
ainsi toute la population à pratiquer
ces disciplines et à pratiquer du sport
et l'objectif c'est d'aider donc ces
personnes en situation de handicap dans
la pratique sportive avec trois piliers
santé recherche formation concrètement
qu'est ce qui va s'y passer dans cet
institut eh bien écoutez c'est un
institut hospitalo universitaires donc
l'idée c'est d'abord d'avoir des
consultations des hôpitaux de jour sur
une approche qui est très transversal
c'est pas le médecin et puis donc avec
des ingénieurs avec des entraîneurs avec
des kinésithérapeutes ergothérapeutes et
c'est l'idée l'idée de se retrouver
autour de ses pratiquants de les aider à
pratiquer de les suivre médicalement on
a pas de recommandations de suivi pour
ces personnes qui pratiquent du sport et
c'est de voir comment aller jusqu'à la
pratique du sport le plus longtemps
possible dans le bien vieillir des
personnes en situation de handicap et
puis on sait aussi que le sport est
pathogène il peut abîmer les épaules il
peut et donc ne pas induire un sur
handicap à ces personnes qui vont vivre
longtemps et qui risque de perte de
l'autonomie s'il se blesse il ya une
dimension formations jouent les dix
formations des professionnels de santé
bien évidemment avec un essaimage
territorial le plus le plus large
possible et puis de la recherche
physiologique est essentiellement
technologique on s'en est rendu compte
avec le co vide il faut commencer par
sortir de chez soi pour faire du sport
il faut se déplacer donc c'est les
fauteuils roulants les aides techniques
les exosquelettes les nouvelles toutes
les nouvelles modalités de déplacement
est d'ailleurs le site sera implantée à
belleville aux mureaux les mureaux c'est
aussi le lieu où il ya un salon qui
s'appelle i tonomy chaque année est ce
que c'est ça c'est fait aussi comme ça
le choix de s'implanter à côté de ce
salon qui justement aborde les nouvelles
technologies au service de l'autonomie
oui oui tout à fait notre partenaire
principal c'est le département a cédé
humide conseil départemental des
yvelines et tout de suite ils nous ont
proposé de nous rapprocher du campus
parce que effectivement il ya des
synergies territoriale autour de
maintenant les mureaux qui serait
extrêmement profitable pour notre projet
ainsi que pour et autonomie et l'idée
est de créer une vraie synergie
territoriale autour de ce projet mais le
projet qui verra donc le jour
officiellement en 2024 même s'il a déjà
été lancé il est saoul et prouve est
aujourd'hui à l'hôpital de garches
exactement on a voulu tester et ouvrir
cette activité dès maintenant sur les
trois piliers dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure afin que en 2024 on puisse eu
juste transféré cette activité est pas
commencer à zéro afin que pour les jeux
paralympiques et surtout pour la suite
tout soit déjà structuré essayé et qu'on
n'est plus qu'à développer mais là
l'objectif d'ici paris 2024 c'est de
profiter de l'engouement pour peut-être
aussi attiré des financeurs sur ce
projet et fit effectivement c'est un
projet très ambitieux et un projet
ambitieux il coûte toujours un peu
d'argent un effort très important a été
fait par le département mais nous
cherchons encore des partenaires privés
et publics pour nous aider à développer
ce projet justement le coût d'un tel
projet vous l'avez estimé le coût était
environ 30 millions d'euros donc il
reste encore des des financeurs à
trouver vous le disais et je voulais
aussi parlé de ce label que a maintenant
7 i/s pcc label héritage paris 2024
qu'est ce que ça veut dire d'avoir ce
label à écouter pour nous effectivement
nous avons nous faisons partie des 170
mesures du plan héritage paris 2024 la
mesure 39 pour être précis et c'est vrai
que ça nous donne un label une certaine
crédibilité et ça nous permet aussi
d'accéder à ce formidable
essor et autour des jeux paralympiques
et et olympique 2024 moi je les ai vus à
tokyo vous allez voir ça va être un
événement extraordinaire planétaire et
qui va porter notre département et la
région évidemment et c'est vrai qu'à
voir ce label est bien ça nous fait
participer à notre petite échelle à ce
projet monumental et est vraiment très
enthousiasmant hillcoat héritage veut
dire forcément qui va se passer des
choses fort heureusement après 2024 avec
notamment sur place il ya un projet
d'incubateur de start-up justement pour
travailler sur la recherche
technologique ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure que vous avez raison l'héritage
c'est de pouvoir survivre et notamment
le faire faire tourner cet institut
après les jeux et avoir du sens pour
pour tout le temps qu'ils ne s'arrêtent
jamais et qu'ils se développent et donc
c'est vraiment ça le le l'objectif de
paris 2024 merci françois genest d'être
venu en plateau et je le rappelle
président de l'iace pc synergie qui
porte ce projet donc l'institut de santé
parra sport connectés qui l'avoir qui
doit voir le jour en 2024 aux mureaux et
on suivra bien sûr avec attention les
évolutions de ce projet le handisport
qui disposera de cinq cent quarante neuf
épreuves aux jeux paralympiques de paris
2024 le programme de l'événement qui se
déroulera du 28 août au 8 septembre a
été dévoilé par le comité international
paralympique et le comité d'organisation
une édition qui se veut est davantage
paritaire
1859 femmes devraient faire partie de
l'aventuré sur les 4400 athlètes
attendus dans moins de trois ans en
france
[Musique]
en 2024 les athlètes amateurs pourront
se mêler aux professionnels dans le
marathon pour tous est une première dans
l'histoire des jeux olympiques le 31
octobre à piles mille jours de la
cérémonie d'ouverture
près de trois mille six cents coureurs
ont ainsi pu défier légende et liu
dequippe choqué il fallait battre le
kenyan de titre olympique recordman du
monde sur 5 km c'est la distance à
parcourir pour y parvenir et laisser un
maximum de chances laisser un maximum de
chance le marathonien avait un handicap
de temps et s'est élancé en dernière
position mille personnes ont réussi à
décrocher l'or de ça pour les jo pour
ceux qui voudraient tenter retenter leur
chance un nouvel événement de
qualification cette fois ci sur 10 km
doit se dérouler avant les jeux un
marathon qui vous l'avez compris ce voeu
inédit et dont le tracé officiel n'a pas
été encore dévoilé elle le départ sera
donné du pont d'iéna c'est acté et
pourrait faire ensuite un passage dans
les yvelines dans les hauts-de-seine et
et notamment c'est une rumeur qui a
émergé dans le château de versailles au
sein du parc du château de versailles le
comité d'organisation est réfléchirai
sérieusement un passage devant la
demeure du roi soleil est le parcours
arriverait à la cité royale par saint
cloud avant de passer par viroflay et
meudon pour regagner paris l épreuve est
programmée le 11 août 2024 dernier jour
de ces jo
tout ça ne reste que des rumeurs alors
que cette information elle est avérée et
confirmé florian rousseau est le nouveau
directeur du programme olympique de
cyclisme pour paris 2024 l ancien
pistard triple champion olympique aura
pour objectif est de faire performer
cette équipe de france de cyclisme sur
piste et de cyclisme en général en 2024
une conférence de presse se tenait au
siège de la fédération française est
début novembre et on en parle avec
michael et demi d'euros
florian rousseau est de retour la
fédération française de cyclisme huit
ans après avoir quitté son poste
d'entraîneur national le pistard vient
d'être nommé directeur du programme
olympique par la ffc il aura pour
objectif de partager son expérience
internationale et son vécu sur les jo
avec notamment trois titres olympiques
mon rôle c'est d'animer de coordonner en
tout cas est de fixer un cap notamment
par rapport aux objectifs de réussite
donc deux médailles aux jeux en paris
2024 d'identifier les besoins pour
accompagner les entraîneurs les acteurs
de la terre fait et des athlètes florian
rousseau aura deux ans et demi pour
remobiliser un groupe france fragilisée
après les jeux olympiques 2021 raté avec
seulement deux médailles de bronze en
cyclisme toutes disciplines confondues
la plus value est vraiment transformé
l'essai lors des jeux olympiques pour ça
évidemment il va construire son approche
il va la construire avec l'encadrement
il va mettre en place une équipe pour
gérer tous les aspects qui lui semble
important autour de la performance c'est
plein d'éléments qui viennent s'agréger
les uns aux autres et c'est tout ce
travail de construction qui doit
l'amener à faire en sorte que à paris
2024 bon soit dans une configuration où
on confirme finalement les résultats
qu'on a dans les grands championnats
internationaux
ce mercredi 3 novembre vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
fédération française espère débuter une
nouvelle ère avec peut-être à la clé
plusieurs titres olympiques en 2024 sur
le territoire évinois en bmx cyclisme
sur piste ou encore vtt un
appareil de 1024 également de nouvelles
disciplines le break dance sera l'un des
sports additionnel du rendez vous fort
de cet engouement la troisième édition
de l' ultimate battle masters se
dérouler en octobre à poissy l événement
a pour ambition de devenir un tournoi
préparatoire aux jo retour avec bixente
mais rien senti steban
[Musique]
il ferait de galles à haubourdin armand
peugeot à poissy ultimate battle masters
c'est l'une des compétitions émergentes
du breakdance cette année c'est une
équipe française qui a remporté le titre
e
c'était assez rude parce que c'était sûr
du temps lui minutes 10 minutes 10
minutes c'est ça demande beaucoup de
temps beaucoup d'énergie surtout que
on n'était pas préparé à ça mais
on a su quand même
bien bien relever la pente et
on a pu gagner cette compétition et on
est très fier de moi et mon équipe une
belle performance dans le niveau était
élevé avec des équipes venues du monde
entier parce qu'on a pu voir ce soir ça
fait partie de l'excellence mondiale
que ce soit le continent européen le
continent africain le continent
américain voilà ils étaient tous
représentés c'est actuellement ce qui se
fait quasiment de mieux pour encadrer
les athlètes un jury de prestige jury
que j'ai choisi sévèrement à la crème au
niveau de hauts niveaux de débits bois
et français on n'a eu qu'à lille qui est
champion de france on a eu lie de kiev
qui est triple champion du monde et on a
eu ce aussi une figure emblématique du
bboying français et qui est aussi
champion de france donc voila et vice
champion du monde du côté des moins de
16 ans l'italien bboy dunger a gagné la
finale face au français le qui je suis
un peu déçu d'avoir perdu en finale mais
là je vais m'entraîner pour gagner la
prochaine fois peut-être le break dance
et ont désormais une discipline
olympique ultimate battle master
souhaite s'inscrire dans les tournois
préparatoires en vue de paris 2024
alors à quoi va ressembler cette épreuve
de break dance aux jo de 2024 et déjà
pour le lieu ce sera dans un stade
ouvert en plein coeur de paris une
transformation temporaire de la place de
la concorde pour accueillir le break
mais aussi le bmx freestyle le
skateboard et le basketball 3 contre 3
après pour le format ce sera tout
simplement des battles une épreuve femme
une épreuve oms s by girls et 16 bboy le
nom débreaker seront qualifiés ils
s'affronteront en 1 contre 1 et devront
enchaîner les figures en s'adaptant et
en improvisant sur le son du dj les
athlètes seront départagés par un jury
pour remporter le premier titre
olympique de breaking d'ici 2024 donc
reste la sélection des sportifs les jeux
de paris ce n'est que dans deux ans et
demi il va falloir faire preuve de
patience encore en attendant cette 33ème
olympiade de l'ère moderne la grande
fête a déjà démarré avec de nombreux
événements en septembre le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accueillait le passage des drapeaux
olympique et paralympique l'occasion
pour le public de rencontrer les
athlètes tricolores les images de
mélanie poker c'est génial de dire qu on
est quand même en train de représenter
les laisse aux salaires fixes et c'est
important que ce seront bien c'est
garder un toit en france on est
impatient on attend et on sera dans
l'équipe de prost la fois constants
paris 2024 ce n'est que dans trois ans
et pourtant l'engouement est déjà
présent
[Musique]
athlètes et non déambuler sur la piste
du vélodrome nationale dans leurs mains
les drapeaux des comités olympiques
paralympiques et de paris 2024 qui
faisaient étape à montigny le bretonneux
ce 18 septembre le compte à rebours des
jeux en france a bien démarré se veut
vraiment dire que ça y est on y est on
est pays on est un pays de l'olympisme
quel pays du paralympiques mme on a
attendu longtemps on a même attendu un
an de plus à cause de la qu'ovide des
jeux qui se dérouleront également sur le
territoire saint quentinois vélodrome
mais aussi golf national à guyancourt et
la colline à elancourt comme sites
olympiques l'agglomération se prépare
qu'est ce qu'elle paie vos que de le
réveiller l'envi de donner envie à
quelqu'un de se dépasser c'est le top
c'est une fois en plus tous les siècles
on peut la voir on est très fiers axuria
pour saint quentin
dit être associés aussi directement
cette cérémonie des drapeaux étaient le
moment aussi de croiser les sportifs qui
rêvent de paris 2024 l'apparat
triathlète cécile sabouraud les pistards
quentin lafargue quentin caleyron timmy
gillion et florian gringo tout
fraîchement médaillé de bronze en
vitesse par équipes c'était l'occasion
pour lui de fêter avec le public présent
donc sur tokyo on n'avait pas forcément
le public ça montre qu'on est soutenue
et s'est joué je me dire depuis le
retour en france c'est là qu'on se rend
compte vraiment ce que sont les jeux
olympiques et on se rend compte que
c'est quelque chose qui touche tout le
monde qui touche à tout pays donc
vraiment content vraiment fier pouvoir
partager tout ça les drapeaux olympique
doivent circuler dans une trentaine de
villes en france prochaine étape dans
les yvelines le 16 octobre sur la
colline d'elancourt
effectivement les drapeaux olympique et
paralympique son passé un mois plus tard
de nouveau par saint quentin en yvelines
le 16 octobre à elancourt la ville
accueillera sur sa colline les épreuves
de vtt en 2024 les trois étendard
officiels ont été présentés au stade guy
boniface en compagnie de thierry rey
ancien champion olympique de judo mais
aussi de sportifs élan courtois le
pistard quentin afane maiva hamadouche
championne du monde de boxe et cécile
sabouraud athlètes handisport une
cérémonie pour célébrer l'esprit
olympique
et pour les territoires hôte de ces
épreuves et qui auront notamment
maintenant la tâche de faire monter l
engouement d'ici à 2024 et bien il ya
des événements aussi qui vont se
dérouler jusqu'à ces jeux olympiques
notamment autour de sports moins connus
- grand public en apparence le golfe et
notamment à saint quentin en yvelines la
discipline prendra ses quartiers au golf
national théâtre de la ryder cup 2018 le
22 octobre dernier le site a accueilli l
édition 2021 de la golf expérience un
rendez vous proposés par l'agglomération
à destination des petits et grands avec
des sessions en nocturne le reportage de
bixente mariens insisté ban
fait
j'aime bien des initiations pour
découvrir le golf au fur et à mesure que
la nuit est tombée le practice de
l'oiseau les du golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines s'est remplie pour
la golf expérience
c'est l'occasion d'essayer la géci et
j'aime j'aime beaucoup l'objectif c'est
de venir entre amis en famille les
familles ou les amis qui sont débutants
vont pouvoir s'amuser avec une un espace
dédié aux enfants différents ateliers on
a des bénévoles qui encadrent différents
ateliers où on va décomposer les
différents coûts est comme ça le
débutant va pouvoir au travers de la
soirée découvrir les différentes
facettes du golfe que ça soit du petit
goût du long jeu sur le practice ou les
d exercice d' approche pour les joueurs
les plus confirmés des outils d'analysé
de swing un concours et un parcours
insolite en nocturne avec des balles
phosphorescente c'est une première donc
c'est un parcours de nuit
on n'a jamais tapé de nuit et sachant
quand même beaucoup les impressions sont
plus les mêmes et le parcours on va le
découvrir je crois qu'il ya trois trous
j'espère qu'on va s'améliorer au fil au
fil du trou après une précédente édition
au golf isabella de plaisir et une
future au blue green de l'île de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines la golf
expérience devient un rendez vous
récurrent du territoire c'est un rendez
vous récurrent il est d'autant plus
important cette année que nous sommes à
trois ans maintenant des jeux olympiques
de paris 2024 et que à saint-quentin
living nous accueilleront la compétition
de golf de paris 2024 ici tout à côté
sur le golf national ce que l'on veut
montrer aujourd'hui c'est que le golf
est bien c'est accessible à tous y
compris pour des petits budgets il faut
casser ces images qui sont d'une autre
époque plus de 300 personnes se sont
rendues à l'événement de ce vendredi 22
octobre l'organisation a même dû ajouter
un second parcours en nocturne en raison
des nombreuses demandes sur l'activité
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro de 7,8
2024 merci de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve dans trois mois pour une
prochaine émission à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]